では これから 紹介の続きとして 話しが始まります
人間の判断ということについて
今日のテーマを持っていきたいと思います
今日は時間は短いですので
あまりこの何でしたっけ？
寄り道をしないで
直接ポイントだけ言って終了いたします
もしわからないところがあったら
後でテープでも聞いて考えてください
時々私にも
仏教のことをよくしゃべったりするんだから
いろんな問題で悩んでいる人々が
もうこの場合は どうすればいいんですか と聞いたりする時もあります
で 私にちゃんとした判断を欲しがっちゃうんですね
で 大体 私は その場合は あまり答えないんです
で なぜかというと
まぁ　こういう問題があるんだけど
どうすればいいんですか と
聞く人が 結局自分で やりたいことは 心の中でも ちゃんとあるんですよ
例えば 人間関係のトラブルで
人がこういうふうに言いますし
こういう問題を作ってるし
じゃぁ どうすればいいんですか と
で 聞いても本当は 答えを聞きたくないんですよ
で 自分で決まってる判断は実行する
あの　何て言いますか
勇気がなくて
で 私に　それで先生もそう言ったんだから といって
それで まぁ やりたいと
それで なんで私は答えないかというと
大体 人々っていうのは
何か問題に出会ったら
自分では答えを持ってるんですよ
その答えは なぜ実行できないか というと
いつでも自分では 相手に勝ちたい と
相手を負かせたいんだ と
という気持ちがあるんですね
相手を潰したいんだ と
自分の意見を とにかく主張したいんだ と
母親が子どもについて 私に相談しても
自分の気持ち
自分の考え方
それを とにかく子どもに 押し付けたいんですね
それは どうすればいいんですか？
と聞くんですよ
そういうふうには 本当は聞かないんです
本当は 色々トラブルがあって
まぁ こういうことなんですけど
どうすればいいんですか と
言葉上では問題ないんですよ
言葉上では問題ないんだけど
心の中ではやっぱり自分の気持ち
自分の考え方
自分の希望
欲望によって相手を管理したい
支配したい という気持ちが はっきりとあるんですね
だから 答えてあげても意味がない
理解しようとしない
で 普通のカウンセリングだったら
まぁ そうですね と言って
なんか褒めてあげればね
さすが お母さんの考え方
あなたの考え方は ちゃんと理屈が通ってるんだよ と
その通りだよ と言ってあげれば
すごい機嫌が良くなって
またその相手の人を 抑えようとするだけであって
正しいことにはならないんですね
正しい 良い結果には 結果が得られなくなっちゃうんですね
だから 最初に そこは気をつけてほしいんですね
我々は いろんな問題について 判断を迫られた時は
結局 私たちは いつでも 自分の意見
とにかく 通してほしい
それは 心の中にあるんですよ
でも 表では言えないんですね
で それでトラブルが起きたりするんですよ
だから 判断の問題で よく考えてほしいのは
ご自分たちで
じゃぁ この問題として
自分の正直な気持ちで どういう答えですか と
それは何かあるはずなんですね
じゃぁ 自分の正直な気持ちっていうのは どんなものか と
それは いいものか 悪いものか と
それから 客観的に 考えてみればいいんですよ
例えば 会社同士の相談があるんですね
どちら側も自分が儲かりたい という
気持ちは正直なんですよ
それを抑えておいて
ただ上辺だけで
この世の中には こういう商売は大変いいですよ とか何とか言うんですね
でも それで あまり相談は成立しなくなっちゃうんです
それで 相手の反論に答えられなくなった時は
やっぱり どういうふうにすればいいんだよ？
どういうふうにすればいいんですか？
とかね
で また考えたり悩んだりする
ですから いろんな判断に悩んでいる人々っていうのは
よく見られることっていうのは
自分では もう初めから 研究もしないで
勉強もしないで
初めからもう答えを持っていることなんですね
ですから 皆様にも そういう経験があるだろう と思いますけど
人の相談に乗ってみたら
まぁ どうしようもない お手上げ状態なんですよ
話しは 聞かないんですね
で せっかく相談に乗るということは
話しを聞くためでしょうに
だから 最終的には 何しに来たんですか？
と聞きたくなるところまで
相手とは話してはいるんだけど
やっぱりどれでも自己主張で
自分の考え方だけ とにかく持っていきたくなるんですね
ですから 人間になぜ判断できないか というと
そこは問題なんですね
自分の意見というのは ものすごい厳密に 持っているんですね
それはもう 自己主張であって わがままなんですね
だから 英語では one side （ワン サイド） ひとつの側面しか見てないんですね
だから 人間に なぜ物事に すべて正しい判断ができないかというと
いつでも そうやって one side で自分の方しか知らない
で 問題は もうだから理解できない
自分の気持ち
自分の感情
その中で もう ぐるぐる回っているんであって
問題っていうのは 自分の感情の中にあるものじゃなくて
やっぱり もう一人と 外の世界との関わりなんですよ
だから まぁ
外の世界の関わりだから
それは考えないで
頭の 心の中だけで ぐるぐる回っても 意味がないんですよ
それは 雷は怖いと思って
耳に 指を刺しても
雷が落ちたら 死んじゃいますよ
それだけで 問題は解決しないんですね
自分の心の中から見れば
音は怖い という ぐらいかもしれませんけど
雷は ざーざーと 落ちるところであるならば
やっぱり 雷は怖い と
だから 目も閉じて 耳も塞いておく
それで安全ですか と
それで 安全なわけじゃないんです
自分の気持ちだけ 落ち着けば いいわけじゃないんです
問題は 外にあるんですよ
ですから
雷が怖いんだったら
雷が落ちてくるんだったら
雷が落ちない場所に 自分が逃げなくちゃいけないんですね
それが答えなのに
目を閉じることで 問題解決しようかな と
ですから 大体 世の中のいろいろな問題 トラブルが起きちゃうと
我々は自分の心の中だけで考えて
ものすごくわがままで 自己主張主義で
自分の意見のみ 通してほしいと思う
それは自分にとっては 気持ちいいんですよ
だから 自分の気持ち
自分に気持ちいい ということは 問題の答えですか と
私は機嫌がいいんだ と
こういうふうになったらという
それで答えにならないんですよ
だから 世の中でみんな生きてる上では
いつでも どのように生きているかというと
自分の気持ちがよければいいんだ と
自分の機嫌が良ければ それでいいや ということで 生きていようとするんですよ
だから ひとつも世の中で 人間というのは問題は解決しないんです
いままでの人類の歴史を見てみても
いろんな問題
しょっちゅう毎日
朝も晩も いろいろ起きてくるんだけど
ひとつも 解決するということはないんです
なんか あっちこっち
ごまかしをしながら
なんとか 生きているだけなんですね
だから 世の中に 一向に平和というものはないし
社会の問題っていうのは 一向に解決したわけじゃないんですよ
でも ずっと人類が現れた時からも 同じ問題を考えているんですよ
子育ては どうしますか？
社会の安定は どうしますか？
経済的な安定は どうしますか？ とかね
家族はどうしますか？ とかね
人間関係 どうしましょうか？
そうやって
ありとあらゆる問題
同じ問題なんですよ
2000年前にも
3000年前にも
いまの時代でも
これからもあるのは
そこまで 考えてきたのに
いまだに 答えがないんです
どんな問題に？
例えば 夫婦が喧嘩しないように と
それは 具体的に 我々にある問題なんですね
だから 男と女が 一緒に生活するということは
人間が現れた時から 来たことでしょうに
やってきたことでしょうに
いまだにそのノウハウ
テクニックを 持っていないんです
いまだに
いまは もっとひどいんですよ
3年ごとに 離婚して 再婚するようになってるんだから
アメリカなんかの いろいろな情報を見ちゃうと
半年間でもう離婚と
また2週間で 他の人と結婚して
また1年で離婚 と
だから もっとひどくなってるんですよ
夫婦で仲良く生活する技は いまだに知らない
だから 人類はずっと昔から何を勉強して
何を理解してきたんですか というと
何も理解していないんです
それは 皆様の社会を見ると
皆様に よく理解できると思います
例えば 教育制度の中で いろいろ問題が起きたりする
子どもたちが いろいろ問題起こしたりする
学校を 拒否したりする
教育も 拒否したりする
あるいは もう勉強したものは 役に立たなくなったりとか
いろいろ問題がある
で それでもう知識人たちを集めて
やっぱり 教育制度を 変えなくちゃいけないんだ とかね
それで 何年も研究して
何年も調べて
レポートでは 答えはなし という
例えば 学校は 6日制
じゃぁ 5日制度にしようか と
いわゆる ひとつの結論のようなものなんですけど
いまだに実行は不可能だ と
ということは あれは答えじゃない ということなんですね
でも もともと6日制度は ちょっと子どもには負担がありすぎや という前提で 始めた考え方なんですけど
同じところに 戻っちゃうんですね
ということは
何ひとつも 理解しようとしないんですよ
ただ 雷が怖いんだったら
もう 耳に指を刺せばいいんだ と
それぐらいの答えで
で なんとか このからくりで やろうとしているだけなんですね
だから その理由は
人間っていうのは
自分の気持ちがよければいい という
立場にいるんです
だから 例えば警察を管理するために
エリートの人々
何人かの組織がありますでしょうに
それだったら そちらの仕事は 客観的に
国民の立場から見て
どのように より良い 安全な社会を作ろうかと
どのように
警察も人間だからね
どうせ 間違いを起こすし
どのように管理すればいいか ということはチェックすることですが
でも そういうことはしないで
まぁ 自分が偉い立場にいるんだからね
それで 機嫌が良くて
気持ちよくて
その自分の気持ちいい状況を 守ることしか 考えないんですよ
それで 役に立たない
国の政治家が
例えば 総理大臣になったら
これ えらい かっこいいんですよ
かなり立場がありまして
すべての権限は 自分で持っていて
国会を解散するなりに 招集するなりに
選挙を興すなりに
何でも自分が判断する
それは 気持ちいいんですよ
それで この気持ちいい立場を どのようにすれば守られるかと
それしか考えないんですよ
だから 問題が起きちゃったら
もう 誰かが書いたメモを読むだけ
問題に答えを持っていないんです
そういうことで 世の中で
いろんな国々で
私は国民を救済して 解放してあげるぞ という偉そうなことを言って 政治家になる人々はいるんだけど
一向に 一人も 国民のために何もやってくれない
だから 政治家が悪いだけじゃなくて
すべての人間というのは そんなものなんです
ですから
具体的に 客観的に 世の中を見ると
人間というのは 何ひとつも
毎日 出会う問題に 解決方法を持ってないんですね
わからないんですよ
例えば 若いお母さんが 自分の子どもの いろいろな問題解決をすることが できなくなっちゃって
お母さんに聞く
自分のお母さんに
あるいは旦那のお母さんに聞く
どうすればいいんですか と
答えを持っていないんです
自分が先輩なのに
自分も 子ども育てて 大きくしたのに
やり方わからない
ですから どう生きるべきか と
問題に どう対応するべきか ということは
どんな先輩に聞いても 全然頼りにならないだろう と思います
で それはおかしいと思うならば
自分の心に聞いてみてください
ご自分 皆様方に自信ありますかね？
若い人々を ちゃんとリードして
ガイドして 導く自信がありますか？
これは正しくて
こういうふうにやって 生きてみなさいよ と
ぴったし 成功するよ と
自分の子どもが 何か問題に遭った時に
自分が相談に乗る
両親に ちゃんと答えられますかね
先輩として
人生の経験がある人として
ですから 自分の心に聞いてみてください
自分に自信がありますか？ と
若者を育てる自信が
任せておけ と
私は年上ですよ と
もう経験済みですよ と
で ないだろうと思います
そんなものなんです
ですから 私たちは先輩に頼っても同じことで
我々の後輩たちも 我々に頼っても
我々も何の頼りにもならない
いい加減 中途半端な考え方で生きているんですね
どこに この中途半端さが 生まれてくるかというと
我々の心の中で 自分の機嫌さえ良ければいいんだ と思ってるんですよ
だから 答えは簡単ですよ
世の中っていうのは
この 私の機嫌という軸に 回っているわけじゃないんだ と
問題っていうのは外にあるんだ と
ですから 自分の気持ち ということをね
それは もう わがままで
我が強い ということ
エゴですね
ですから この我々の心は 自分の中に 入ってるんですよ
外を見てないんです
だから 外から何が触れるか と わからないんです
大体 まぁ そういうことで 何か理解できるだろうと思いますけどね
ですから この 自分の気持ち
自分の好み というものはね
置いといて
外に問題を持ってきて
いわゆる 私はよく言う
この客観性ですね
客観的に 何でも見るならば
すべての問題には すぐ瞬時に 答えが出てくるんですよ
ですから 自分の問題についても
それも 自分自身を 客観化すれば
一切の問題は 解決するというのは
仏教の ずっと言っている立場なんですよ
だから 宗教とは正反対かもしれません
宗教というのは あくまでも主観で
哲学的にしゃべろう と言ってますけどね
で 仏教は 主観を捨てろと
それ自体 間違ってるんだ と
物事は 客観的に見ましょう と
主観というのは ありえないんだ と
主観というのは ありえないんですよ
よく考えてください
自分には 自分の意見というものが 何かあるんですか と
我が強い 頭が悪い人々は 堂々と言うかもしれません
ありますよ と 言っても
ちょっと 環境が変わっちゃえば
その意見は もう ぐるっと 変わっちゃうんです
例えば 私は人間として立派で
なかなか怒りません と
まぁ どんな問題があったって
私は もう怒りませんよ とかいう
まぁまぁ これは いま もう
50歳ですよ と
いまだにもう 全然 怒ったことはないんですよ と
言っても
ちょっと 条件を変えてあげてください
何か言ってみてください
怒るか 怒らないか と
怒り出しますよ
だから 我々は 笑うなりに 笑って 明るい人生をしているんですか？
あるいは 暗くて 文句ばっかり言う 暗い人生か
あるいは 怒りっぽくて
もう そういう苛立ちだけの 人生かと
あるいは アホで 何でも失敗する
何でも壊す
何でも もう むちゃくちゃに 邪魔にしてしまう
無知的な 人生か とかね
そういうものは すべて自分 ということじゃなくて
やっぱり 外の影響から 出てくるんですよ
だから 主観っていうのは もともと ないものなんですよ
で 外から入ってくる情報が 自分の心の中に
そこで処理して 何かを反応する
だからそれ自体が私のもの
私の考え方
私の意見
私の生き方と思うと
その人は 仏教で言う おろか者ということなんです
私の意見というのは ありっこない
私の気持ちっていうのは もうないんです
その気持ちは すぐ変わってしまいますから
変わってしまいますから
ちょっと環境が変わっただけで
そういうことだから
あまりにも 私たちは 自分のものでないものを
自分のものや と ものすごく しがみついているんだから
一向に 問題っていうのは解決しないんですよ
じゃぁ
それは一応
今日のテーマの答えでありまして
それに付け加えて いろいろポイントを考えてみましょう
で 世の中で
もしかすると いろいろ問題が起きた場合は
完璧に正しい答えっていうのは
あり得るんでしょうか と
大体は 完璧に正しい という答えは ないかもしれません
ある場合も ありますけど
ない可能性は 多いんですよ
だから物事っていうのは その場その場で できるものだから
次に どんなことになるか ということは わからないんです
だから 我々は大体 トラブルを起こすひとつの原因というのは
一番正しい答えというか
完璧な 完全な 答えを探そうとしてるんですね
この完全な答え
完全なものを探しているんだから
一向に見つからない
それでまた 自分の主観が ものすごく揺れてしまって
もう 苦しみになってしまうんです
結婚するために 完璧な相手を探す
で 完璧な相手を探す人は 一生 結婚できなくなっちゃうんです
結婚しても 不幸になっちゃうんです
だから 完璧な答えがないんですよ
そこら辺を 理解すれば
我々には 完全に納得できることは 何ひとつもないんだ と
ありえないんだ と
まぁ どこかで 手を打たなくちゃいけないんですよ
それはすべて 人生はそういうふうに なっているんです
じゃぁ そこら辺で手を打ちましょう と
お見合い写真を いっぱい持ってきて
まぁ ひとつ選ぼうと思ったら
女の子だったら これもダメ
これもダメ
そういう性格だったら
世界中の すべての男の写真を 持ってきても
すべて ダメになっちゃうんですね
だから まぁ そこそこで
まぁ まぁ これぐらいで いいんじゃないかな と
その どこかで手を打つ気持ち
考え方 それを持っていくと
かなり 軽々と 生きていられると思います
それは なかなか ない　やらないんですね
子どもが生まれてきたら
もう 完璧な子どもになってほしい と
それは 恐ろしいわがままなんですね
恐ろしい自己満足なんですね
自分の満足のために 子どもを ずっと いじめてやるぞ という
でも 口で言うのは
あなたは 立派な人間にしてあげたいんだから
お母さんも お父さんも そう頑張っているんだ と
それは 立派な人間にしたいんではなくて
あれは 人の肉を食うような感じで言う 恐ろしい行動なんですよ
人食い人間なんですよ
ですから 完璧な子どもを育てると思う場合は
大体 99パーセント 失敗するでしょうに
だから どこかで 手を打たなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 完璧な教師もいませんし
完璧な子どももいませんし
完璧な母もいませんし
完璧な父親もいませんし
完璧な家庭も ありません
完璧な社長も 完璧な社員も 世の中ではいません
よくも 他人に この完全性を求めること
そうそう接する 恐ろしい考え方なんですよ
自分がだらしなくて
ろくでもない生き方をしながら
相手に完全性を求める
相手が完全でなければ腹が立つ
そういう生き方では どんな問題も 解決できるわけじゃないんです
ただ単に 問題を作るばっかりで
次から次へと 問題を作る
だから 嫌な存在になっちゃうんですよ
一人のそういうふうな人が来たら
もう次に問題を作る
それを何とかして また次に問題を作る
それを何とかすると また次に問題を作っちゃう
このトラブルだけの
みんなに迷惑だけかける
頭を悩ませることばかりする人々も いるでしょうに
それは 他人に対して完全性を求める
時々 恐ろしい子どもたちがいるでしょ
親に暴力を振るうは
学校で暴力振るうは
言うことを聞かないわ
不良に走るわ とかね
なんで そうなったんですか？ と
母が悪かった と
平気で言うでしょうね
学校の先生が悪かった と
自分が何なのか と
それは見ようとしない
自分が不良に走ることは
それは放っておけと
それは放っておけ でも母が悪かった と
母が厳しかったんだから
私は自由を探す
探して 自分でやりたい放題やるんだ と
でも 母がやりたい放題やるのは
それは ダメですよ と
母が奴隷みたく 子どもの言うことを 全部 聞いてあげなくちゃいけないんだ と
そういう考え方でしょうに
だから 人がだらしなければ だらしないほど
他人に完璧になれ と
完全になれ と 命令する
希望する
脅迫する
いろんなことをします
ですから 正しい答えっていうのは
世の中では成り立たない
ありえないんです
ですから
この心の中に
他人に
厳しく 完全性を認めることを やめた方がいいんです
まぁ よく世の中であることなんですけど
ですから
もし何か問題があったとする
その問題に何か 我々は答えを出したりする
その答え自体は 完璧というわけじゃないんですよ
だから 我々は better（ベター） というね
まぁまぁ
これぐらいの答えで いいんじゃないかな と
というぐらいの レベルの答えを 出さなくちゃいけないんですよ
答えはこれです と
２足す２でしょ
だから４です と
５にはなりません と
そういうふうには 人生は成り立ちません
ですから
まぁ これぐらいでしょう と
という答えは出す
そこで 出した答えも 次に うまくいかない時もあります
なぜならば 完璧な答えじゃないんだから
条件が変わると
まぁ 自分が出した結論も 合わない時もあります
それで 答えを出した人が 決めた人が
正しく決めたならば
じゃぁ 調整しましょう
では 変えましょう と
だから我々は 決めたものでも
常に 調整する必要があります
それに いろんなところを 変える必要があります
これこそ ということじゃないんです
で 世の中でひとつ問題っていうのは
私が そう決めたんだから やりなさいよ と
ものすごい 頑固で言う人々が いるでしょうに
これは命令だから
社長命令だから
そうやって決めたんだから
会議で決めたんだから
だから 結果が どうであろうと
もう TPOも 何も考えないで 実行しようとする
実行させようとする
そういう頑固さも
何なのか と
それは 本人はやっぱり自分の判断
自分の命令
完璧だ と
完全だ と思っているんだからなんですよ
まぁ 一応 こういうことだよ というふうに判断すれば
その TPOに応じて
その occasion （オケージョン） に その場所に その時間に 応じて
あ やっぱり ちょっと調整した方がいいんじゃないかな と
だから 人には まず決断
判断できないにも関わらず する
した決断 判断には 頑固と 執着して とらわれて
変化は認めない
評価しない
許さない
もう アホも いいところなんですよ
例えば 簡単な例で言うならば
まぁ 子どもは 毎日学校に 行くべきですよ
でも 熱出したり 病気になっちゃったら
家で休んだ方がいいでしょうに
それは当たり前のことで
毎日学校に行くべきです
だから 言葉だけに引っかかったら
毎日学校に行くべきですよ と言ったら
もう たとえ熱が出ても
だから そんなことぐらいで もう
ちゃんと 学校に行きなさい ということになっちゃうんですね
だから そういうのは いつでも 変化しなくちゃいけないんですよ
調整しなくちゃいけないんです
例えば 必ず 学校に行くべきですか と
義務教育だから
そうでもないでしょうに
自分一人で 他の方法で勉強するんだったら
勉強して 試験だけ受かれば
それでも十分でしょうに
そういうことだから 必ず そうでなくてはならない ということはね
大変 問題なんですよ
例えば 日本だったら
大学だったら
なかなか いくら天才の子どもであろうか
10歳で 15歳では入れませんね
小学校 中学校の勉強っていうのは
例えば 一年で終わってしまった と
でもダメです
ちゃんと 学校に行かなくちゃいけないんです
行かなかったら 卒業しません
できません と
高校を 卒業してないんだから
年数稼いで
これぐらい これは あんた教育を受けてないんだから
まぁ 大学の入学は 拒否するんだ と
という あまりにも無知的で
あまりにも頑固なんですね
特別なケースもありますよ と
ということはないんです
ということで 決めたんだから こう ということではないんですよ
正しく決めた人が 正しく決めた ということは
完璧な答えを 出したわけではないんですよ
より良い答えを出す ということなんです
それは正しい判断なんです
出した人はいつでも
まぁ この場合は こうしましょう
この場合はこうしましょう というふうな調整はする
だか ら瞑想をなさっている方々もにも よく言いますけどね
で 基本はこういう基本なんだけど
ずっと調整しなくちゃいけないんだ と
でも みんな どこかで ある決まりに はまってしまって
あるしきたりに はまってしまって
それだけで ぐるぐる回りたいんですね
だから なかなか 成功しない
それは 身をもって 経験させているはずなんですけど
それぞれなりに それなりに 調整して
前へ 前へ 進むようにしなさいと
だから この性格の悪さ
この頑固さっていうのを はっきりと体験できるんですよ
ヴィパッサナー瞑想でもやってみたら
それは どんな人間にもある問題で
だから 世の中っていうのは問題だらけで
答えは ひとつもないような 世の中になっているんですね
ですから
いま 言ったポイントっていうのは
我々には いつでも この訂正する能力
調整する能力
それは大変立派なことなんです
生き方においても
勉強においても
仕事においても
どんなものにおいても
自分が判断するんですが
自分が決めたことでも 何でもいいんだけど
常に調整する
車を運転するときは 我々は steering wheel （ステアリングホイール： ハンドル） に つかまっているでしょうに
それで 運転する人々は 常に 調整しながらいるでしょうに
はい これでOK と　手を離しますよ と いうことは できませんでしょうに
車がブレーキをかけて ギアを入れて ストップするところまで
steering wheel からは手を離してはいけません
だから すべての 生まれた時から 死ぬまで
これ 人生そのものが
動いている 移動中の 車の steering wheel と 同じなんですよ
人生には止まる ということが 瞬間もないんだから
だから 素晴らしい人間っていうのは
自分の瞬間瞬間の生き方っていうのは
この運転中の 車の steering wheel だと思って
常に 何でも 調整する能力があること
これ 大変なことなんですよ
立派な人間なんですよ
だから 悪い例なんですけど
政治競争で 生き残る政治家っていうのは 誰ですかね？
よく調整するんですよ
だから そうやって いろんな この党に入る 次に飛んでいって
他のところに入って また元に戻って
また他のところに行ったり とかね
あっちこっち カエルみたいに 飛び回ったりするでしょうに
ろくでもない生き方かもしれません 政治家として
でも 本人が何とかして生き延びるんですね
だから 2年前に言ったことと 今日 言ってることは
もし もう全部記録してるんだから 比べてみると
何や この人と
ポリシーがないんじゃないかな
言えるぐらいでしょうに
でも そこで その人は 正しいわけじゃないんだけど
なんで いろんな党を ぐるぐる回ったりしてね
野党になったり 与党になって また野党になって
いろいろ ぐるぐる 回ったりするかというと
これは 我が身はかわいいんだから なんですよ
別に 国民のために やっているわけじゃないんです
だから この主観的であることは もう その通りだから
あの調整は 立派な調整じゃなくて
ただ だらしないだけ
自分の身を守るために いろいろ
もう からくりやったり 調整したりする
そういう調整を みんな やってますけど
それは だらしない だけのことで
私が言うのは
ちゃんと自分で客観的な判断しても
やっぱり うまくいくように
人生に 事故を起こさないように 生きるという
人生のsteering wheel を ちゃんと握って 調整していくことなんですね
だから ポイントは 調整する能力
英語で言うと adjustability （アジャスタビリティ）
はい では次のポイント
私たちは何か判断したところで 間違っちゃうでしょ
だから 怖くて 判断できなくなっちゃうんですね
はっきりと イエス と ノー と 言えないんですね
はっきりと 白か黒かで 決められない場合もありますね
決められないんじゃなくて
やっぱり決められない
決めたところで
あ しまった と
これは違う と　間違った と
で 間違うことが怖くて
最初から もう決めないで
優柔不断状態に なってしまうんですね
なんで 我々の判断 結論を 間違えますか と
それは怖くて
なんで 優柔不断になるんでしょうか と
答えは 簡単です
心が 頭が 腐ってるんです
あまり 明確に しゃべる時間がないんだから
さっさっと はっきりと 言いますけどね
この はっきり判断できない人
それから した判断はとんでもない 間違っている
場合は もう 簡単な答え
心が腐ってるんですよ
心が 醜い 汚い
だから できないんですよ
で 心が腐ってるって どういうことかというと
まぁ 例えば 自分が儲かることしか考えない
これ 腐ってる考え方でしょうに
これ 主観的でしょうに
儲かる ということは
他人との関わりの結果として 生まれるもので
それを 客観的に見ていないんですよ
商売で 儲かる ということは
他人との関わりの結果なんです
だから うまく関わりを持つこと
正しいんであって
じゃぁ 儲かりたい
だから こうします だけでいっちゃうと
かなり 判断ミスを起こして 大変なことになります
それは このバブル時期というね
日本で なぜ現れたかというと
この 心が みんなに 腐っていたんだからなんですよ
経済学者は 一人もいなかったからなんです
経済の世界の 論理の基本 基礎を
知ってる人も いなかったんだから
でも インテリ中のインテリなんですけど
なんで インテリ中の インテリたちが
銀行の 管理やってる人々が
日銀の偉い人々が
平気で 国民をね
落とし穴に 落としちゃったんですか と
ひどい苦しみに合わせたんですか と
リストラばっかしで
それ 威張ってるんですよ
リストラして 儲かってるんだ と
そんな 威張ることじゃないんだから
だから そこは 心が腐っていたんだからなんです
儲かるんだ と
だから やれやれ と
それだけの考え方で
これだけの結果が 出てくる
で まぁ
崖に 落ちてもいいんだけど
崖に 落ちたまんまで 登ろうとしないんです
登りたいな と思ってるだけで
まだまだ 登る方法が見つからない
だから 問題は作るんだけど
解決法は ないんです
心は 腐ってるんです
だからそうやって この自分
欲
それから 怒り
それから 嫉妬 憎しみ
そういうもので 我々は
人間と 関係を持ってるんですよ
対立している 政党2つが お互いに
ディスカッション テーブル （discussion table） に来ても
相手の方は 憎しんでいるんですよ
潰したいんですよ
だから ディスカッションやっても
いい結果が出てこないんです
韓国の政治家と 北朝鮮の政治家が 同じ round table （ラウンドテーブル）ですか
座って じゃぁ 国際的な会議をやりましょう と
いつでも 物別れで終わっちゃうんです
他 そう言ったら 韓国人は悪いように 感じるかもしれない
そういうことじゃなくて
誰でも 同じことで
日本とソ連が 何か話し合うといっても
やっぱり 答えが出てこない
来年にします と
再来年にします と
何千万円も お金が かかってね
政治家たちが
話し合ったりして
その政治家の人々はね
1時間の対談というのは すごいお金がかかるでしょうに
もうね そろそろ なんとかサミットも やるでしょうに
私は あぁいうものはね
ものすごい お金がかかる
究極的な 贅沢な お祭りだ と
何人かが 1時間で
1,000万円以上の単位で お金を使って お祭りをする
一人の国の政治家が 来るということは
大変な すごいお金がかかるものだから
1 分単位で計算してみれば
どれぐらいお金がかかるんですか と
で お祭りをやって 物別れで解散する
写真だけ ビデオだけで 握手をして ニコッと笑って
笑ってはないんですよ
歯を出して 終わっちゃうだけ
無駄ですよ あんなものは
じゃぁ どこかで 正しく判断したことが ありますか？
例えば 日本も IMFから いろんなことに ヨーロッパに
向こうで 言われたい放題 言われて 帰ってくるんですよ
こちらは まぁ
で 厳しい判断で ニュースを 見ていると
日本に対しては 厳しい判断でした とかね
だったら 自分たちでも 自分の言いたいことを 言ってみれば いいんだけど
まぁ なんとか 言わないか どうかは わかりませんけど
とにかく みんなに いい結果を出しましょう という
国際会議では ないんですよ
だから 対立している2人が 3人が
あるいは 違う意見を持ってる 何人かが集まって
国際会議であろうが
個人的な会議であろうが
まぁ 仏教の会議であるか
国際仏教会議も ありますからね
私は 一度も行ったことはないし
行かないし
世界仏教協会とか なんとかも ありますけどね
で 行かない
意味はないんだから
お祭りやって お金使って
そんな暇があったら 寝るぞ と
で 行かない
行って 祭りをやって まぁ 喧嘩したら あまり意味がないんだから
祭りをやって 終わるんですよ
例えば 日本やら 中国やら 大乗仏教の国々と 南の仏教の国々を集めて 国際会議をやりますよ
毎年 やってます
じゃぁ 現代人に必要な
そういう 大乗 小乗の対立のない
すごく平和的な 仏教の生き方は 見つかったんですかね
誰一人も 見つかってない
各宗派から行く人々は 自分の意見だけ 主張して
それで もう 言ったら 困りますから
じっと我慢して
じゃぁ ご飯食べて 写真撮って
で みんなと 名刺交換して
一回 日本で 国際会議に 偉い人々が あっちこっちからね
宗教から 来たんだから
私も やっぱり 挨拶に 行かなくちゃいけないことになっちゃって
挨拶に行ってみたんだけど
まぁ 日本の偉い人々と 各国の偉いお坊さんたちやらね
宗教の人々が来て
で 名刺交換しながらね
私も いっぱい 名刺を持ってきて
もう 来い と
あれ 飾っておけば
あんた この人の名刺を持っているんですか？ と
すごい かっこよかったかも しれませんけど
残念ながらね
まぁ いま思い出しても 遅いんですけど
捨てたんです
そういうことで 人間に 異論がある場合は
なかなか答えが出てこない理由は
心が腐っている
怒り 憎しみ
欲
自分の意見を 通してほしいと
それだけでは 会議やっても 全然 意味がない
だから 私は言うのは
なぜ 我々の判断を間違えますか と
なぜ 我々は 判断しないで
なんとか もう 延期するんですね
来年にします と
北方領土は 来年にします という
そのディスカッションは 私が日本に来た時から あったんですよ
まぁ 2000年になっても まだ 答えがないんです
政治家は ぐるぐる 変わりますけど
ソ連でも 日本でも 話し合いもしますけど
だから 答えが なければ
あの時間は 無駄でしょうに
あのお金も 無駄でしょうに
なぜ 答えが出てこないかというと
やっぱり 自己主張
それは 問題なんです
だから 人類の頭が 心が 腐りすぎなんですよ
貪瞋痴で
怒りで 憎しみで 欲で
だから ものを見えるはずがないんです
怒りも 欲も 憎しみも すべて主観的だと 私は 最初から言ったんだから
主観というのは 本当は もう いい加減なもので
ちょっとしたことで 変わりますから
ちょっとしたことで それは 変わりますでしょうに
だから 何の意味もないんです
それにしがみついて 頭が悪くなるだけ
だから 正しく 答えを出すために
たったひとつの方法が ありますよ
まぁ 心は
心の汚れを落とすということは 結構 時間がかかりますから
で もう 最初からもね
生命に対して 平等な気持ちで
人は 負けてはよくないんだ と
自分の態度で
自分の判断で
自分の決めたことで
誰かに 迷惑をかけたら
誰かが 負けてしまったら
誰かが 不幸になったら
誰かが 損したら
それは 自分としては 立派じゃないんだ と
たとえ 会社の相談であろうとも
両側も 得しなくちゃいけないんだ と
子どもと相談に乗っても
やっぱり 両側は まぁ よかった よかった と
両方 得するように しなくちゃいけないんだ と
ですから 得するようにしましょう と思ったら うまくいかないんだから
お釈迦様が言うのは
他人に対して 限りない慈しみを持ちなさいよ と
相手に 迷惑をかけてはいけない
相手に 損させてはいけない
相手を 苦しませてはいけない
相手も喜ぶような方向へ 導かなくちゃいけないんだ と
そういう気持ちを持って 行動すると
いとも簡単に答えが出てくる
そういうことで 我々の心が 憎しみではなくて
怒りではなくて
嫉妬ではなくて
欲ではなくて
慈しみで 起動させちゃうと
いつでも正しい答えが出てくる
例えば
森の中から 熊が出てくるんだ と
言った途端 出す判断は
じゃぁ 行って殺そう と
危ない と
それは 正しい答えじゃないんです
熊が出るんだ じゃぁ 行って殺そう
簡単 単純で
これ自分たちだけの答えでしょうに
すると 熊には 何の権利もないんです
熊が 何か悪いこと したんですかね？
何も 悪いことしてないのに
で 殺そう と
だから 人間同士で そうでしょ
平気で じゃぁ 殺そう と
言って 殺してるでしょうに
個人で 個人を 殺しちゃったら 殺人ですけど
集団で 集団を殺す
殺人でも なんでもないでしょうに
立派な行為だと思ってるでしょうに
戦争とか 解放運動とか 何とか 名前をつけちゃって 大量に殺す
その場合は 殺人罪でもなんでもない
ヒーローなんですね
だから そういうのは 人間の正しい生き方ではないし
だから 熊が入ってきたら
じゃぁ 熊を殺そう ということではないんですよ　答えは
だから まぁ
我々も 安心して
熊にも 自由に生きていられるように 状況を作る ということなんですけど
そう考えちゃうと ちょっと ややこしくなるんだから
仏教で言うのは そうじゃなくて
逆に 熊のことを考えなさい と
熊に対して 慈しみを持ちなさい と
この熊さんが 気持ちよく 自分の世界で 生活できるように どうすればいいんでしょうか と
そうすると 熊に安心して 生活できるような状況にしてあげれば
熊は もう 面倒くさいんだから
人家に入ろうとはしないんです
熊も 好きで来るわけじゃないんだから
動物は 人間のことをものすごく怖がって 嫌いなんですよ
だから 森の中で生活できれば 落ち着いて 生活しますよ
人に 他人に 迷惑をかけない　動物は
餌を食べたら グーグーと 寝るんだから
それ以上 何もしませんからね
ですから 他人に対して 慈しみだけ持てば
大体 答えが すぐ出てくるんです
そこで言いたいのは
答えっていうのは 私が持っているわけじゃないんですよ
これは 1番目のポイントに また戻りますけど
みんな 話し合いはするんだけど
最初から 答えを持っている
あれ とんでもない話しなんです
私が言いたいポイントは そうじゃなくて
答えを持ってないんだ と
持っているのは 問題だけですよ と
頭の中にある固定概念で 感情で 作った答えは 忘れるんです
あれは 答えじゃないんだ と
私の主観だけだ と
だから 答えは 持ってません
それで 対立している問題が出てきたんだ と
その時は 相手に対して慈しみを持って
じゃぁ 考えましょう ということで
考えてみると
そこに 答えが 現れてくるんです
だから 正しい答えっていうのは
決して 前もって 作っている答えではありません
その場で 新しく誕生するんです
それは よく覚えていただきたいんです
どんな問題でも
答えというのは テキストにあるわけじゃないんです
聖典 経典にあるわけじゃないんです
自分の経験の中に あるわけではないんです
どんな問題も 新しい問題ですから
そこで 他人に対して 慈しみで ものごとを考えちゃうと
そこに 新しく
誕生するんですよ　答えが
それを 覚えておけばね
うまくいけると思います
答えっていうのは 新しく誕生するものだよ と
reborn （リボーン）
そこで 相手に親切に 我々は行動したりする
その場合は 物事を考えなくてはいけないんですね
例えば 国際問題にしても
中国と日本の間の問題にしても
韓国と日本の間の問題 　いろいろ
アメリカと日本の問題にしても いろいろ問題があります
皆様にも いろいろ 個人的に いろんな問題があります
そういう問題がある場合は
母親と子どもの間に 問題が起きたりする
夫婦の間で 問題が起きたりする
いつでも 相手がいるんですよ
で そこで 相手に対して親切に
相手に対して 慈しみを持って
相手の幸せを思って 考えたりする
それで答えが誕生する
そういうふうに考えるために 必要なのは
仏教で大変有名な言葉なんですけど
この言葉なんですね
yonisomanasikāra （ヨーニソーマナシカーラ）
経典のどこを読んでみても
お釈迦様は なぜ人が間違いますか？
なぜ 悪い行動をしますか と
なぜ いけない考え方を作っちゃうんですか と
なぜ 世の中で戦争やら トラブルやら あるんですか と
なぜ 人間が幸せになりたいと思って
苦しみしか作らないんですか と
すべて この yonisomanasikāra がないんだから と
これ 否定形で ayonisomanasikāra （アヨーニソーマナシカーラ）と言うんです　その場合は
だから これから お釈迦様の経典なんか 読んでみてください
どんな問題でも 問題について お釈迦様が言うのは
これは ayonisomanasikāra ですよ
だから 問題をなくすためには yonisomanasikāra というものが 必要なんですね
で これは なかなか日本訳しにくい 言葉なんですよ
日本訳もしにくいし
英訳もしにくいし
何でしょうか と
ということは 人類に答えが ないんだからなんですよ
いまだに ひとつも問題解決したことないでしょ
だから 我々の頭の中で yonisomanasikāra っていうのは
1個 あったことはないんです　一度も
だから 日本語にしても 英語にしても ドイツ語にしても
単語さえもないんです
それは お釈迦様が お話しした言葉で
本当は 訳しにくいんです
じゃぁ 意味は言いますけど
これは 物事を客観的に見なさい という意味なんです
でも yonisomanasikāra を 客観的 と翻訳したら 間違っちゃうんですね
だから パーリ聖典を翻訳するときは 決して 客観的 とは翻訳しません
なぜならば 仏教は客観主義だ ということは
どんな仏教学者も わかっていないんだから
もうひとつの宗教だと 勘違いしているんだから
お釈迦様は 偉い科学者でした と わかってないんですから
だから 私は言葉を調べたところで
はめる言葉というのは 本当は 客観的 ということなんです
で その中で見方も入ってるんです
どのように物事を見るんですか と
yonisomanasikāra
manasikāra っていうのは 考えること
この manasikāra っていうのは 考える という意味なんです
思考
この 考える場合は
yoniso　あるがままに
順番に という
この あるがままに というのは
あ こういうことで
こういう問題が起きた
こういう原因で
このように見ているんだから
こういうことが起きた と
すごく 客観的に観察することが yoniso なんですよ
例えば 子どもが 「学校に行きたくないから」
「そんなこと言ったら 困りますよ」と すぐ反応を出すでしょうね
それは客観的じゃなくて 主観的
自分の気持ち
自分の心配なんです
で それで喧嘩になっちゃうんですね
だから 子どもが 学校に行きたくないと思ったら
あ 学校に行きたくない という問題があります と
なぜ そういう問題が起きたか と
それで 客観的に 分析してみればいいんです
別に とにかく 学校に行かせてやるぞ とかね
そうやって 自分の意見を出すんじゃないんですよ
客観的に分析してみると
すぐ 新しく 答えが生まれてくるんです
だから 相手に対して 親切に yonisomanasikāra で やらなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば いま 出した例ですから
子どもが 学校に行きたくない と言ったら
いっぱい質問すれば
あるいは
いつから 学校に行きたくなくなったんですか と
今日 初めてですか と
昨日もそういう気持ちでしたか と
そうすると 時間の経過が わかるでしょ
一番最初に 学校が嫌だな と思ったのは いつでしたか と
その時 どういうことでしたか と
そうやって 時間の経過と流れを 理解してみる
それ同時に その原因と こちらの対応
子どもの態度
それは ちゃんと 把握できる
で 最初に 子どもにも気持ちがありますから
子どもは主観的だからね
あなたは 正直なところ
学校に行きたいんですか？
行きたくないんですか？ と
それもありますから
本当は 行きたいんだけど
行きたくない という気持ちもあるし
いえ 人が何を言おうと
学校は　家に戻ろう と
私は 行きたくない 参加したくない という場合
また 違いますからね
で それひとつ
それから あなたは 勉強は嫌いですか？　そうではないのですか？ と
そういうことも ありまして
将来について どう考えているんですか？　考えてないんですか？ と
どのように考えているんですか？ と
自分の人生設計は どういうふうに 立てるつもりですか？ と
そうやって たくさん質問さえすれば
問題が ちゃんと見えてくる
もしかすると 答えは
この子は 勉強は 好きかもしれません
でも 学校の環境 雰囲気は 自分に合わないかもしれません
逆に 学校に行かせたら 悪い結果に なるかもしれません
だったら
あなたにとって 特別な勉強をする方法を 探しましょう と
学校はいらん と
あんた そういう気持ちで そんなに勉強もできて
勉強も好きでしょうしね
こういう勉強したいでしょうし
だったら じゃぁ そういうふうに やりましょう という答えが出てくるでしょうに
最初から なんとかして 子どもを 学校に行かせてもらって
それで終わり と
という気持ちで 答えが出てこないんです
だから 問題が起きたら 答えが新生する
新しく生まれてくるんですよ
それは 相手も こちらも 予想したものじゃないんです
それに必要なのは この yonisomanasikāra ということ
yonisomanasikāra は だから 日本訳もない言葉なんですけど
すごく客観的に わかりやすく言えば
物事の順番
なぜ この問題になったか と
いきなり 突然 問題というのは現れません
ゆっくりと 現れるんですよ
たとえ 予知できない地震にしても
いきなり突然 地震が起こるわけじゃないんです
我々は知らないだけで
地下にある いろいろな活動があって
その活動を ゆっくり積み重ねて
地震という結果になるだけ
決して ある日突然 地震が起きた ということはありません
何年も ゆっくりと 地下で行動が起きて
やがて 地震 ということですからね
だから どんな問題でも ゆっくりと 順番で 成り立つものだから
その順番を 見てみる
原因 関係と見てみて
大きくなった問題は また 小さくして持っていくためには
どういう順番で よろしいか ということだけなんですよ
だから そんな簡単に イエスか ノーか とかは 出てこないでしょうね
それは yonisomanasikāra ということなんです
もうひとつ 言葉を覚えておきましょう
これは反対の言葉で
お釈迦様は こんなことだったら 地獄に落ちますよ まで 脅している言葉なんですよ
ditthiggāha （ディッティガーハ）
で こんなことをやったら
もう どうにもならないんだ と
あまりにも 激しく ditthiggāha になったら
地獄に落ちるんだよ と
そこまで 脅しをするところまで 大変な言葉なんです
やってはいけないこと
yonisomanasikāra というのは 我々にあってほしいこと
ditthiggāha というのは 自分の意見を
ものすごく 意見に囚われて しがみついて いくことなんです
自分の考え方に
いわゆる 主観 ですよ
yonisomanasikāra は 客観
だから自分の意見に
自分の主観に
これこそ正しい と
ものすごく しがみついていること
ditthiggāha と言うんです
自分の意見にしがみついていたら
救いの道がないんだ と
どうにもならないんだ と
真理は 一向に わかりっこはないんだ と
それは もう 徹底的に 避けた方がいいんです
自分には 意見があるかもしれませんけど
それは まぁ とりあえず ということで
とりあえず 私はこういう意見ですけど ということなんです
ditthiggāha しがみついているわけじゃないんです
まぁ 条件が変わったら 変わりますよ と
あなたは 全く もう すごい良い意見を出すならば
私の意見を変えますよ と
まぁ これは 例で考えれば
例えば 夏休みは
北海道に行こう と 決めたところで
相手は 「北海道じゃなくて もっと安くて 台湾旅行ができますよ」 と
「もっと面白いんですよ」
「北海道は どうせ日本だから」
そしたら
「あぁ そうですか だったら台湾に行こう」 ということなんです
「いい 私が決めたんだから」
「人が何と言おうとも お金がいくらかかろうとも 北海道に行くんだ」
というのは ditthiggāha なんです
まぁ とりあえず こういうふうに 考えているんだけど
もっと すごい いい計画があったら
じゃぁ そちらに変更します というのは ditthiggāha じゃないんです
だから 人生において よく気をつけてください
すべての人間が ditthiggāha なんです
自分の意見は 変えたくない
だから yonisomanasikāra は なし
単語さえもない
英訳しているテキストを 見てみたんだけど
適切な英訳じゃないんです
なんとか訳するだけで
その訳は 訳だから
私が言う意味は どこにもないんです
私は 実際に 実践の世界で
お釈迦様は どのように この言葉を使っていたか ということは
現代の言葉で言うだけだからね
そういうのは どんなテキストでもないんです
あ もう 時間は終わりましたけど
そこで この中道って何なのか ということで あと10分以内で なんとか終わります
え？
え？　2時間までじゃないの？
長すぎ それだったら
じゃぁ そういうことだったら
もう さっさと 終わりまで言います
そこで 皆様が よく聞いている言葉っていうのは
Majjhimā patipadā （マッジマーパティパダー）
「中道」 ということなんですね
仏教は 中道である ということは
これは 誰でも知っています
誰でも知っていますからね
仏教は 中道ですから
でも 誰も 仏教の人々も知らないのは 「中道」とは何ですか？ と
それは何？ と
まぁ 試しに 遊びに いろんな宗教家に 聞いてみてください
仏教の中で
もう いろんな宗教に 分かれているんだから
まず 「仏教というのは中道ですか ということをご存知ですか？」
「えぇ まぁ その通りですよ」 と威張って 言うかもしれません
これ 「中道」って 何なのか と
聞いたら いろいろ意見が出ると思います
結局は 「仏教は中道であり」 ということは 知ってますけど
この 「中道」 は何なのか というと わからないんです
それだったら 何の役にも立たんでしょうに
だから 中道って何なのか ということを はっきり理解していない
で みんな思うのは
この 中 道 だから
真ん中の道や と
それって同時に いい加減な道じゃないんですかね
真ん中の道です
両極端的な意見が 2つ ありまして
じゃぁ 半分半分で
じゃぁ ここら辺で 真ん中にしましょう と
そうすると いい加減な道なんですね
そこで 龍樹かな
この真ん中の道は悪い と
という 数学的に 説明するんですよ
例えば 何か意見があるね
それは間違っているんだ と
極端だから
それに 正反対の意見がある
それも極端だから 間違っている と
じゃぁ 真ん中にしましょう と
真ん中っていうのは
ひとつの完璧な悪い意見の 半分でしょ
もうひとつの完璧に悪い意見の 半分でしょ
じゃぁ 完璧に悪い半分が合体したらどうですかね
半分足す半分は 1でしょうに
もうひとつ 完璧に悪い意見が 生まれてくるだけなんです
例えば 左は 間違ってるんだ と
で 極端的な右も 間違ってるんだ と
で 真ん中ですよ と
そういう意味じゃないんです
そうすると 真ん中も 間違ってますよ
だから「中道」っていうのは 決して 曖昧という意味ではないんです
だから私は 日本訳する場合は 「超越道」 にしましょうと
「中道」ではなくて
人間の道とは 違うんだ と
人間には何も 判断 決断はできない
問題を作るだけの かたまり ですからね
こういう 人間の道ではないんだ と
これは 「超越道」や と
で 仏教で中道というのは
いつでも 正しい判断が できるような生き方なんです
間違いを 犯さないような生き方なんですよ
だから 今日は 判断のテーマだから
だから 判断というのは
どうせ 間違っちゃうでしょうに 普通に判断しちゃったら
意見が2つあると
とにかく相手の意見を潰そうということでやるでしょうに
そうすると 強引な人が勝ちますけど
それは 正しいわけじゃないんです
例えば 世の中で アメリカの意見が通じているでしょうに
だから 正しいということはないんですよ
向こうは もう強引だから
力が強いんだから
力で抑えちゃうだけ
それで みんな 「はいはい わかりました」と
他の国々は 行動する
そんな強引に 自分の意見を押しつけても
それは 正しいわけでもないんです
例えば 中国について アメリカが
人権問題とか 偉くしゃべる
それで世界中みんな
やっぱり 中国は もう本当に 人権問題を真面目に考えなくちゃいけないんだ と
勘違いもする
じゃぁ アメリカはちゃんと 人権を守ってますかね
自分の国の中で
自分たちもやりたい放題でしょうに
大した差がないとは思いますけどね
中国とは
でも 自分たちの生き方が 正しいんだから やりなさい と
それは 中国人にとっては 大きなお世話なんです
我々には 我々の生き方があるんだと
だから 商売の話しだったらしましょう と
政治の話しだったら もう ごめん と
で 帰るんです
まぁ そういうふうに問題が起きたら
そういうふうなことが出てきたりする
ですからこの 人間というのは
二人がいて
問題を作っちゃうと
力強い人が
一番頭の悪い人が 自分の意見を通してもらう
自分の意見が いろいろ批判されると 腹が立って 怒って
感情的になって
暴力まで振るったりして
とにかく 自分の意見を通してもらおう と
それでも通らない場合
私は出て行くぞ と
もうあんた方とは何の関係もないんだ と
それも暴力なんですね
とにかく 自分の意見が通って欲しがっちゃう
それやるのは 正しい答えではありません
ただ 中道というのは いくらか手を抜いて
いくらか手を緩めて ということですかね
それも 正しくないんですよ
だから 前に説明したように
相手に対して慈しみを持って
それから yonisomanasikāra で 客観的に考えたら
自分が持っていた答えでもなく
相手が持っていた答えでもなく
新しく誕生する 二人にも 賛成できる答えがあるんですね
それが 中道なんです
単語がなかったんだから
お釈迦様も 「中道」という言葉を使ったんですけど
なぜかというと 「超越」という言葉はあるんですよ
お釈迦様は それは違う場所で使っているんです
ですから お釈迦様は この人間の実践方法に
中という言葉に majjhimā という 見る という言葉を使ったんですね
だから そこは はっきり理解しないで
これは 真ん中の道だと思ったら
それは えらい誤解になっちゃうんです
真ん中の道ではありません
これは 超越の道なんですね
ですから
この 超越の道を発見した人
身についた人が 超越した人間だというんですよ
その教えに 超越した教えだというんですよ
だから 違うところで超越という言葉を 使っているんです
uttari manussa （ウッタリマヌッサ） という言葉
だから uttari というのは 「上」ということで
乗り越えている ということ
manussa
人間の生き方は もう 乗り越えている と
だから 他のところで 使っているんだから
この 中道には使ってないんです
で 理由がありますよ
中道を実践する人が 普通の人間だから
実践した結果で
普通の人間は乗り越えられますから
だから 結果に 「超越」という言葉を使っているんです
道に使ってないんです
まぁ そこは ややこしいんだから
そこら辺は 別に忘れてもいいんですけど
そこで 二人が話し合っている場合は
私にも 私の意見があって
相手にも 相手の意見があるんだけど
それは もう 主観ですからね
まぁ とりあえず こういう意見だよ と
それで 話し合っちゃうと
あぁ 二人にも賛成できる考え方は こういう考え方ではないか と
新しい考え方が出てきます
その新しい考え方が 中道の判断なんですね
だから 自分が負けたわけでもないし
勝ったわけでもないし
でも 損していないんです
答えが 自分には 大変いい答えなんです
相手も 勝ったわけでもないし
負けたわけでもないし
でも 出した結論は 相手にとっても すごく この上ない結論なんです
だったら 万々歳でしょう
いろんな国際問題もね
そういう立場で見るんだったら 解決方法は出ますよ
例えば 台湾という島がありますね
それは 中国のものや と
もう 一向に 頑固に 中国は決まってるんです
で いままでは 西洋の国々は 中国っていうのは 台湾ですよ と
中国という国はないんだ と
言って 中国大陸は ないように していたんですね
でも 地図にありますからね
政治になくても
国連の
5つの国が 権力を持ってるでしょ
そこでも 台湾が入っていたんだから
で それで世界平和だ と
あるわけないでしょ
まぁ とにかく後で
一応 中国になってましたけど
で 一旦 中国を認めるようになってきて
それで 中国は 台湾は私たちの土地です と
台湾の国は私たちのものや と言わないんです
台湾という島
その土地
中国のものです と
それ すごい頑固なんですね
でも 台湾人がそうなりたいか と
で また 違う意見でしょう
それで 怖い問題が出てくる
そこで もし台湾は 中国の一部になったら どうなるか と
台湾の人々に対して どうなるんでしょうか と
経済活動は どうなるんですか？ と
生き方はどうなるんですか？ と
あの政治システムが嫌だから こちらにいるんだから
あれ 台湾人が損する
すべて自由を 失ってしまう
経済成長も なくなってしまう
豊かさも なくなってしまう
じゃぁ どうすればいいんですか と
そこで 中国の主張でもなく
台湾の主張でもなく
何か あるはずなんです
中国も まぁ これだったらいいんじゃないか と
台湾も まぁ これだったらいいんじゃないか と
という答えが あるんですよ
ちょっと考えれば
だから そういうふうに
いろんな問題を 解決できるんです
どんな国々の問題でも
で そこは 国際的な問題だけではなくて
民主問題でも何でも
人間の問題でも
親子の問題でも
そうやって 考えちゃうと 中道的な答えが出てきます
この中道的な答えっていうのは
Aさんの意見が 通ったわけでもなく
Bさんの意見が 通ったわけでもなく
Aさんにも Bさんにも 一番いい答えを出すことなんです
時々 イスラエルの問題にしても
まだまだ解決してないんだけど
一応解決しなくちゃいけないんだ と
なんとかしましょう というところまで 行ったのは
そういう 第三者が入って
ノルウェーなんですけどね
入って話しをしたからなんです
ノルウェーの国が 別にもう イスラエル人万歳 ということでもないし
パレスチナ人万歳 ということでもなくて
お互いに どちらの方がいいんですか と
両側のことを 心配して
これで大変や と
あんた方 殺し合いばっかし やっていてね
だから 二人にも いい方は何でしょうかと 考えましょうと 言ったところで
両側も じゃぁ 話しましょう と
だから 三人で話し合って
いくらかの 決まりに なったんですね
それで 後から アメリカが自分が やったんだという
それは 大嘘で
ただ 入り込んだだけ なんですけど
で サインする時は アメリカの大統領がいて サインしたんだけど
本当は 後ろに隠れているところで ノルウェー人の代表者もいたんですね
したのはその人なんですけど
だから立派な人なんです
なぜかというと そのために 喧嘩しなかったんですよ
あ どうぞ どうぞ
威張りたければ どうぞ
その方が もっとうまくいくんだ と
アメリカを 立ててあげたら
どうせ あの国は小さいしね
力もないし
立派だと思いますね
だから そこで 何か どちらにでも認められる答えが 出てくる
それでなんで パレスチナ人とユダ人の問題
なんで あの一応契約を書いたのに
なんで うまくいかないかというと
いまだに 自分たちだけ 得することを 考えているんですね
取った土地をあげたくないんだ と
で パレスチナ人も 暴力を振るおう とかね
だから うまくいかないのは
まだまだ 中道の考え方に なっていないんだからなんです
だから 得するんだったら 両方が得しなくちゃいけない と
という気持ちにならないと
それには わがままを捨てなきゃ 決して成り立たないんだ ということに
自己主張を捨てないと 成り立たない と わからないとね
そういうことだから
正しい結論を出す道
仏教では 「中道」 と言うんです
majjhimā patipadā というんです
それは 真ん中の道ではなくて
超越した道なんです
それで 次のポイントに行きます
じゃぁ それから 中道って何なのかと
これは 曖昧なものか と
いい加減なものか という問題なんですけど
お釈迦様は この曖昧な いい加減なことを 中道だとは 言ってないんです
これは はっきりした生き方だ と
これしかない 生き方だ と
中道っていうのは もう選択がない
そういう生き方だと 説明しているんです
ですから 中道って何なのか というと
お釈迦様が 最初に言うのは 正見
パーリ語で Sammā diṭṭhi （サンマ―ディッティ） と言うんですね
次に 正思惟かな
どなたか 書いてください
いまは それだけでいいんです
また後で来て下さい
で 最初に 正見
この 正見というのは 自分の主観
自分の意見
それ 捨てなさい ということ
客観的に見なさい ということ
まず 考え方から 始まらないと
私の意見だから といってね
私は これを信じているんだから
そういうふうに 言っちゃうと
頭が良くなるわけじゃないんです
ですから この超越道 正しい判断をしたければ
まず 自分の頭は しっかりしなくちゃいけない
それで問題は
じゃぁ 正見って何なのか と
これ わからないでしょうに
それで お釈迦様は 答えを出してる
正見というのは
物事は一時的でありますよ
固定してないんです
なんでも
今日は優しい子は 明日も優しい というわけじゃないんです
固定しないんですよ
今日 優しい子は 明日は 乱暴になるかもしれませんしね
今日は 100点取ったんだけど
次のテストで 40点かもしれません
物事 ひとつも 固定してないんです
何ひとつも
それは よく理解しましょう
だから 人間が問題を起こしちゃうのは
自分が考えたことで ずっと一生 やりたがるんでしょうに
そうは うまく いかないんですよ
たとえ 国に憲法を作っても
それで100年頑張りましょう とは ありえない話なんですよ
憲法を作るのは その時の条件と もうちょっと 将来のことも考えて
頑張っては作りますけどね
でも 世の中の条件やら 国の条件やら いろいろ変わりますからね
たとえ憲法であろうとも
改正しなくちゃいけないことには なるんですよ
法律だからといって固定していますか？　法律は
固定してないんですよ
その日 その日で 新しい法律が 出てくるんだから
古い法律を 変えたりするんだから
例えば 18歳までは 子どもですよ と
犯罪には問いませんよ と
言われたところは すごい うまいことに使っちゃって
12歳で 人を殺す
17歳 11ヶ月で 人を殺す とかね
18歳になってないんだから
それで ただでご飯食べて
もう楽々に 社会に戻る と
やりたい放題です その場合は
ですから そういうことを やってくると
やっぱり 法律を変えなくては いけないんですね
アメリカのどっかの地方で
殺人だったら たとえ子どもであろうとも
他の問題の場合は 子どもは 子ども扱いするんだけど
殺人だったら 普通に裁判を起こす と
まさかもう 子どもまで そんなことをやり始めたんだから
ですから
18歳未満は子どもだよ という法律は 固定しているわけじゃないんですよ
これを 変えなくてはいけないことにもなります
もう その条件に応じて
ですから 世の中のことは 何でも変えて 変化していく
なんで それを理解しないか と
自分が結婚した相手が 自分に対する愛情っていうのは
結婚したその日で あったような感じで 一生あると思ったら
それは 大間違いなんですよ
愛情であろうが
それは その日 その日で お互いの関係によって 成り立つものなんですよ
固定して 安定してないんです
それで みんな失敗するでしょうに
奥さんのほうが 旦那さんの方が 自分のことを 大変愛しているんだ と
これは変わらないだろう と 勘違いしたところで
大変な ひどい目に遭っちゃう
で 男の人も 自分の奥さんだからね
自分のことしか考えてない と思ったところで
とんでもない結果に なってしまう
で 結婚したんだから といって
男女の間に 愛情は もう決めました と
神様が決めたんだから と
そんな嘘は 世の中に 成り立ちません
だから 結婚する相手は 神が決めているんだ というふうに
西洋的な思想があるでしょ
本当にそうだったら
結婚したら 離婚しないはずなんですよ
離婚の数が 一番多いのは
この 神様を信じてる世界でしょうに
でも 結婚は 日本人も求めて 教会でやるんですね
ああいう 間違っている考え方に基づいて やるもんですよ
神様の前で誓いをして とかね
まぁ 邪見に基づいた 嘘の誓いだからね
もう 1ヶ月間か
2ヶ月間で もうダメになっちゃう
だから 仏教でいうのは すべて変化するんだ と
だから 夫婦は 仲良くしたければ
死ぬ日まで お互いに 心配し合ったり
労わり合ったりしなきゃ あかんですよ
10年間 お互いに労わり合ってきても
11年目から 無視するようになっちゃったら 別れてしまいますよ
お互いに 口をきかなくなっちゃうんです
ですから この正見というのは
それを理解すること
何ひとつも 固定していないんだ と
例えば 私は いま ベラベラ しゃべっているんだから といって
この能力は ずっと あると思いますか？　それはないと思います
もし もう おじいさんになったことも
私にも起きちゃったら 終わりだから
わからないんですよ
ボケてしまったら
それで終わりでしょうし
だから もう 何でも固定していない
だから 瞬間 瞬間 努力しなくちゃいけない
で 大学に入って
例えば みんな やっていることだからね
受験までは真面目に勉強する
あ やったんだから ということで
大学に入ったから それっきり 死ぬまで 勉強しない
だから 教育レベルは高いんだけど
頭のいい人は ほとんどなし という
状態になっているでしょうに
だから そういうことは 良くないんですよ
頭が 良くなって欲しければ
毎日 頑張らないと
ゴールポイントは ないんですよ
死ぬときまでは
ですから
正見というのは どんなものも conditional （コンディショナル） 条件によって 成り立つもので
固定していない
変化していく
変わる
明日 次に どうなるかわからない
そういうことや
それから 何やっても 別に 意味があるわけじゃないんだ と
例えば 何か 決めるでしょ
正しい決め方じゃないでしょ
例えば ある人が 音楽家になりたいと決める
その決断は 正しいんですかね
正しくないんですよ
ただ その時の条件によって そう決めただけ
ある人が 建築家になろうとする
ある人が 何かになろうと思ったりする
若い時は
それは 正しい判断ではありません
間違っている判断でもありません
まぁ とりあえず その条件で そう決めただけのことで
そこで 音楽家になろうと 思ったんだけど
研究もしたんだけど
練習もしたんだけど
まぁ 大変な苦労や と
食べられません と
あ これは 収入にならない
プロにならない と 思っちゃう時は
もしかすると もう 歳も取っていて
他の仕事を探すと
それでも収入がない と
そういうことにも なりかねませんし
あるいは 結局 虚しいんじゃないかな と
そんなことをしても
大したことじゃない とも感じるでしょ
そう感じることは 正見なんです
いわゆる 我々は 決断して 何をしても
最終的な結果っていうのは ろくな結果じゃないんです
たとえ 音楽家になっても
だから 何でしょうか と
たとえ すごい医者になってもね
それで人生 成功した？　どうってことないんですよ
ただ 患者さんを いじめてるだけで
弁護士になろうと思って 弁護士になったとする
ただ嘘をついて 人のお金を奪ってるだけで
結局は 虚しいんですよ
じゃぁ 教師になってやるぞ と思って 教師になっても
立派な教師になれるわけじゃないし
死ぬまでか 退職するまで
同じ年の子どもたちと 一緒に生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
自分には 何の成長も なくなっちゃうんですよ
例えば 小学生の先生だったら
退職するまで 小学生相手でしょうに
えらい つまらなくなると 思いますよ
毎年 毎年 同じこと
同じ問題
だから 同じ年で 同じ問題作るんだから
同じ教科書
すごい つまらないと思います
だから そこは理解しなさいよ と
この世の中で 完璧な ぴったしという判断
生き方は ないんだ と
まぁ とりあえず 何か選んで やるんだ と
まぁ それも結局は 最後には 虚しくなるんだ と
それを理解することは 正見なんです
物事は 固定していない
変化していく
何か決めても
大したことでは ありません と
決めたことは 大胆に
時代の革命みたいな？　そうなりません と
例えば アインシュタインさんがね
いろいろ ものを考えたりしたんだけど
いまから考えて
まぁ どうったことない と
ということに なるでしょうに
そういうことは 正見
だから 曖昧ではありません
それを理解してください と
だから 経典を読んでみてください
苦であること
渇愛
苦 集 滅 道
それを理解することは 正見だよ と
と言っているのは そういうわけなんです
だから 正見では 私は正しい意見を持ちましょう と
そういうふうには 成り立たない
正見持って 教育者になります と
正見でもって 子どもを育てますよ と
そんな正見というのは あるわけじゃないんです
それは正見でもない
単なる主観で
正見というのは 物事は固定していない
変化していくんだ
何か決めても すぐ変わってしまうんだ
決めたものは しがみついてやったとしても
最終的には虚しいんだ と
そんな どうってことは ないんだと
すべては dukkha （ドゥッカ） であると
という理解があれば
もう 頭は綺麗なんですよ
どんな判断もできる
その人には
次に正思惟
それから 人間というのは いろんなことを考えるでしょ
だから 考えては間違う
考えては間違う
考える時は いつでも 主観で考える
客観で考えることは なかなか できません
皆様方が 大体 客観的に考えるのは
数学の問題解決をするとき
それから 将棋とか
ゲームをやっている時は まぁ 主観的じゃないんです
主観的だったら 将棋は負けますからね
その時は 将棋板の上にある駒の配列で 考えるんです
これはこれにあって
向こうは こういうふうに あるんだから
じゃぁ こうします と
そういうのは 客観的な考え方なんです
普通に考えてると すべて主観的なんです
今日は 何を食べようかと思ったら
それは 結論は はっきりと主観的なんです
将棋の板の上で 考えたような感じで 考えたことじゃないんですよ
だから 上手な将棋のプロだったら
ひとつの駒を動かしちゃうと それしか選択はないんですよ
決まりは これです と
また 20回ステップを 考えているかもしれませんけど
1番目は これ
そうすると 向こうは こうするしか方法はない
で 2番目は この駒を動かすと
それは 客観的な考え方
で 夜に何を食べようかな と思う時は 客観的じゃないんです
なぜならば
それしかない ということじゃないでしょ
夜は 天ぷらにしましょう と
その人には それしか食べ物がないんですかね
天ぷらを食べなかったら 死ぬんですかね
いえ ラーメンを食べても 同じことなんです
ですから その場合は主観的なんです
そういうことは 考える世界の問題なんです
だから お釈迦様はね
この考え方は 気をつけてほしいんですよ
気をつけて と言っても
正しく考えなさい と言っても
どう考えればいいんですかね
じゃぁ 正しく考えるんだ と
できるんですかね
できないんですよ
正思は できないんだから
また お釈迦様の智慧が 出てくるんですよ
こういうふうにしたらどうですか と
怒りを持って考えては いけません と
相手のことを 憎んで
憎しみに基づいて
憎しみの感情で考えるなよ と
怒りの感情で考えるなよ と
何か考えるとか
あぁ 嫌だな あの人のこと という感じになってきたら
まぁ だからこうしましょう と
その判断は 良くないんです
相手のことを怒って 考えたんだから
それから 欲に基づいて
考えてはいけません
欲に心が汚れていたら
その考え方を やめるんです
で  3つあります
3番目は
他人をね 潰したい
暴力をふるいたい
壊したい という
この 破壊的な気持ち
どうすれば 我々は 戦争に勝ちますか？ とかね
そういう 破壊的なことは 考えないこと
例えば 悪い人がいて
その人を殴りたくなる
で 殴って あるいは 殺したくなる
で いきなり殺しちゃったら 自分が捕まりますから
いろいろ 考える
計画立てる
計画を立てて 他の人と仲良くしてあげて
また 紹介してあげたりして
その人に まぁ 殺されるようにする とか
それで 自分がセーフだ と
そういうことで 世の中で いっぱい犯罪は 起きます
だから 相手に対して 暴力
害を与えるような気持ちが生まれたら
まるっきり そういうことを 考えないこと
だから やめることは
3つしか ないんですよ
それだけ やめて 自由に考えればいいんです
欲ばっかしで 心が汚れていて 汚染したら
もう そういうことを 考えないようにする
怒り　苛立ち
暗闇が 出てきたら
その思考は ストップする
例えば 私は 何をやっても ダメだな とかね
うまくいかないんだ とかね
そういう 暗いでしょうね
それは 怒りなんですね
まぁ いいわ そんな考え方は 暗いんだから と
すぐ そこをやめる
やめちゃって テレビでも見た方が いいんです
テレビでも見ると あの考え方は 出てこないんだ と
あるいは 音楽でも聞いた方が いいんです
あるいは 何か本でも読んだ方が いいんです
そうやって
正思惟というのは いきなり育てることは できません
できませんから
やってはいけない思考だけを
3つ 覚えておいて
それは 避ける
そうすると すごい 精神的に
心理学的にも 完璧な人間が 成り立つんですよ
この心理学的には みんな いろいろな問題を 起してるでしょ
消えちゃうんです
それは 考え方が まずいんだからなんです
まぁ そういうことで
まず 考え方から 問題解決するんです
それから 我々の生き方
生き方の場合は
どんな生き方が 正しいか とか
これまた わからないんですよ
子どもを 叱った方がいいんですか？
親切にした方がいいんですか？
甘えさせてあげた方がいいんですか？
わからないんですよ
ずっと甘えさせてあげたら また 悪くなっちゃうし
厳しくしちゃうと また 悪くなっちゃうし
叱ることばっかりやっちゃうと また ダメになっちゃうし
褒めることをしちゃったら
また 子どもの能力は なくなってしまうし
どうすればいいかと わからないんですよ
仕事の場合でも 同じこと
張り切って 仕事をしても
あまり うまくいかない時も あるし
あまり 自分が張り切りすぎて 他の人と かみ合わない時もあるし
じゃぁ 中途半端にやったら それまた ダメでしょうし
じゃぁ ほどほど といっても ほどほどって どれぐらいかと わからないし
どうでしょうかね
例えば 自分の奥さんに対して よく褒めてあげればいいんだな と
そうすると 向こうは機嫌が良くなって
まぁ 家庭を守るだろうと 思って
まぁ よく褒めると 向こうは 馬鹿にしちゃうんですね
で 褒めないで無視しちゃうと
また もう腹が立ってくるんですね 向こうは
だから 人間にとっては どうすればいいか ということは もう わからないものなんですよ
だから お釈迦様が だったら 簡単な方法で決めましょう と
で  3つ
Sammā vācā （サンマーワーチャー） Sammā kammanta （サンマーカンマータ） Sammā ājīva （サンマーアージワー） という
3つを教えるんですね
それだけ 頑張って 守ってください と
Sammā vācā 正語
正しい言葉を しゃべってください と
じゃぁ 正しい言葉をしゃべってください といっても
何が 正しい言葉ですかね
わかりますかね
正しい言葉って 何でしょうか と
例えば 自分が言ったことは
他の事実と比べてみれば そうでないかもしれませんし
科学の世界ではね
昔 何か発見して
これこそ真理だと 一生懸命教えてって したんだけど
新しいものを発見して
あれ　間違いました と
そうすると 前の先生たちは 何を教えたんですかね
だから 何が正しいかといえば
今日 言ったことは 明日で変わりますから
だから 単なる正しい言葉といっても わからないんです
だから お釈迦様は これだけ守ってください と
まず 嘘を言うなよ と
だから いま 事実だと認めているものを 言えばいいんです
明日 それは事実でなくても しょうがないんですよ
今日は これは事実だよ ということを しゃべればいいんです
だから 事実なのに
それをねじ曲げて 嘘を言う
それは やめなさい と
それから 人にね
きつい言葉を言ったり
叱ったり
人の気持ちが悪くなる言葉
それ やめましょう と
暴力的な言葉
人の気持ちが すごく嫌な気持ちになる
叱りの言葉とか
あれはやめた方がいい と
何の結果にもならない
ただ人間関係が悪くなるだけ
それから 噂は やめましょう と
噂っていうのは 相手の悪口を
その人がいないところで 言うことなんですよ
これは もう みっともない性格なんですよ
人の悪口は その人いないところで 平気で言う
なんか 噂話をする人間っていうのは
何か あの 汚水道みたいなもんで
まぁ どこでも 汚いものばっかし
流しているような感じで
東京ではないんだけど
田舎に行くと トイレの あれは運ぶでしょ
なんか 車が来て
それで 一旦運んで どこかで処理するんだけど
それを もし
あれを開けて ずっと
あちこち 漏らしていっちゃうと
どんな調子ですかね
世界中 汚くなって 臭くなっちゃうでしょうに
嘘を言う人は 嘘じゃなくて
噂を言う人は そんなタイプなんですよ
どこに行っても 臭いんです　しゃべるものっていうのは
だから そういう言葉は やめてください と
で 逆に いい言葉
人の いいところね
だけしゃべるようにしてください
そうすると 自分が どこへ行っても
香りがいい 人間なんですね
そこで 4番目
無駄話は やめなさい と
無駄話は 頭が悪くなる
時間は 無駄
それから 終わりがない
いくらでも しゃべれますから
聞いた人の 役にも立ちませんし
しゃべった人の 役にも立ちませんし
ただ 時間の無駄だけ
それで 頭が良くならない
ですから 無駄話はやめなさい と
それは 正語なんですよ
だから 何が正しい言葉か というのは
こんなことは 決めることは できません
だから やってはいけない言葉だけ 理解しておけば 生活しやすいんです
すごく 人格が出てくるんです
もう 2つありますけど
全部 3つもセットがあって
で 4番目は
体の行動なんですね
我々の 行うこと
やること
やることは 全部 正しいことをやってください という意味なんですけど
何が正しいですかと わからないでしょうに
ですから
例えば 道路の掃除を すべきか ないか とかね
もう わからないんですよ 正しいか
ですから そこで やってはいけないことは あるんですね
他人の生命
他の生命を 殺すことだけは やめましょう と
で それから 盗んだりすることを やめましょう と
邪まな行為をすることを やめましょう と
簡単ですよ 3つだけ やめれば いいんです
行動は まぁ 自由ですよ
他の行動は自由です
その 3つだけ守って行動すると 正業 なんです
他人の 生命を 殺すことは もうやめる
たとえ 動物であろうが 殺さないことにする
物を盗ることはね
盗むことも やめる
で  5番目は 正命 になるんですね
正命っていうのは 仕事なんです
人間が 何か 仕事をしないと
これ 正しい命 ではありません
漢字が 間違ってるんです
昔から 仏教の世界で
漢字が間違ってるんだから
解説も すごく 間違ってるんです
ある人は 自分が ブッダの生まれ変わりだ と言ってね
で それも嘘なんですけど そこで ブッダだから
八正道を語らないと ブッダになりませんからね
人の考え方を盗むなよ と 言いたいんだけどね
自分がブッダだから 自分でしゃべれば いいでしょうに
正命のところを 説明すると
むちゃくちゃ
これは もう 霊魂のことであると
霊魂は ちゃんと磨いて 綺麗にしなくちゃいけないんだ と
科学では もう わかりません と そんなことは
だから 科学は 科学にあらず とかね
まぁ 病気もいいところですけど まぁ そんな
だから なぜ間違うかというと
これは もう どこかで 誰かが 一般人向けに書いた 仏教の本でも ちょっとずつだけ読んで
もう そういうことだから 専門家でも誰でもないし
だから 中国で 正命 という字を 入れちゃったんだから
その字は ちょっと 間違ってるんですよ
ājīva というのは ライフスタイルであって
生き方なんです
パーリ語の ājīva
サンスクリット語の ājīvaも そういうことなんです
何をして 生きているんですか？ ということで
だから 正命 の字は 間違っています
だから
どんな言葉が いいんでしょうかね
ライフスタイル というかね
一般的に言えば 仕事って意味なんですけどね
何をして 食べてるんですか？ と
何をして 生活を つなげているんですか？ と
何をして 自分の命を つなげているんですか？ ということなんですね
ですから 本当は
生活とかね
でも 「正生活」は ちょっと あまり
音はね あまり 綺麗じゃないし
まぁ 簡単な 英語で言えば
この ライフスタイル という
だから 英訳はRight living （ライト リビング）と英訳するんですよ
これは Right living と訳するんです
だから 生活 なんですよ
で 人間っていうのは 何かをして 生きていなくちゃいけない
動物もそうでしょうね
仕事なく 生きていられませんよ
だから生命には
餌はね 口に自動的に入るとかね
は ないんです
動物にしても 仕事をしないと
だから この世の中で 生まれたものは
誰でも 何か仕事をして 食べているんです
それは 避けられないんです
で まぁ ヒヨコだったらね
口に自動的に入りますけど
赤ちゃんだったら
まぁ 一応 自動的に 食べ物は 口に入りますけど
それ以外は もう 無理ですよ
なんとかしないと
ですから 正しいことをしなさい と
生活として 正しい仕事をしなさい というと
どんな仕事が 正しいんでしょうかね
これまた 決められなくなります
ですから
やめる仕事
こういう仕事だけは やめてください と
仕事のために 殺すこと
仕事のために 盗むこと
仕事のために 邪まな行為を すること
それだけ やめてください と
他の仕事は 自由ですよ
収入さえ 入れば
ですから この 正業 で言ったこと
同じことを 仕事にも するなよ と
まぁ 時々いますからね
別に 自分個人では 人を殺したりはしませんけど
仕事上は 殺す と
いるでしょうに
それは やめてほしい と
それで 生き方
はっきりしていますよ
それも わかりやすく
やりやすく お釈迦様は おっしゃいますよ
これ やりなさい ではなくて
これ やめなさい と
そうすると 把握できるでしょうに
やりなさい ということを 言っちゃうと
どこまで言えば いいんでしょうかね
時代によって それは 変わっちゃうでしょうに
もし お釈迦様が ちゃんと 農業をやって生活しなさい と言ったならば
いまの時代 どうしますかね
そうすると お釈迦様の教えが 時代遅れになっちゃうんです
仏教徒の仕事は 農業であるべきですよ とか何とか おっしゃったならば
そういうアホなことを お釈迦様は しません
だから いまの時代にも ぴったし合うように
この仕事だけは やめなさい と
3つぐらい やめてもらう
他のことは 自由です
ですから
車の工場でも 飛行機の工場でも
普通の会社でも 証券会社でも 仕事はできます
どこでも
でも 人 生命を殺すことは できません
盗むことはできません
証券会社で 仕事をしているんだから といって
本当は 損するのを 知っている上に
お客さんを騙して
やっぱり いいですよ 投資してください と 言ってね
人のお金を 盗ったりして
それで 会社は儲かるんだけど
あの人は 全部もう 倒産するとか
そういうこともやらせてるでしょう
そういうのは 盗みですね
そういうことを しないで
正直に頑張れば いいんですね
それで 生き方
で 次に ものすごく 大きな問題が出てくるんです
まぁ なんとか 生きていられます
でも 正見が 出てくると
すべては 虚しいでしょう 結局は
どんな生き方をしたとしても
大した ろくな生き方じゃないですよ
音楽家になったとしても
医者になったとしても
弁護士になっても
普通のサラリーマンになってもね
結局は 年取ったら 退職して
それでまぁ コソコソと 死ぬだけのことなんですよ
で たとえ日銀の総裁であろうともね
退職しちゃったら もう何のこともない
まぁ インテリだから どこかで
60 歳まで 仕事は見つかるかもしれませんけど
でも 年取ってくると ボロボロでね
判断能力もなくて
あまり 役に立ちません
だから 90 歳になっても できる仕事っていうのはね
たとえ ボケても できる仕事っていうのは ひとつしかないんですよ 世の中に
政治家になること
だから 人間 いい加減でも そういうことでしょう
政治家になる資格っていうのは ないんです
でも 普通の ちっぽけな会社に 入るためには
やっぱり 履歴書を 持って行って
いろいろ 資格を見せて
試験を受けて
面接を合格して
行儀よく振るまって いろいろ 苦労しないと
採用してもらえないんですよ
で 頭がおかしくて
精神的な病気でない限りは
普通の 正気の人間だったら
まぁ 選挙に出られます
まぁ 嘘言ったらダメですけど
ない学歴を書いたりしちゃうと ダメなんですけど
そうでない限りは 大丈夫です
それで 退職はなし
でも 一番大事な仕事ですよ
面接なしで よくも そういう仕事に
国の 全責任を 持っているところなんですけど
そちらには 資格は要りません というんだから
大体 人類っていうのは いい加減ですよ
それは 日本も同じで
外国も 同じなんですよ
政治家になるために 何の資格も 要りません
それは シンガポールだけ 厳しいんです
大統領選挙なんかに 出る場合は
ちゃんと 自分がふさわしい という 免許をもらわないと
自分も投票が 何といいますか
選挙に出るんだ ということは
選挙管理局に出せないんです
選挙管理局に出す場合には もうひとつ 証明書が必要なんです
国の大統領になるぐらいの 能力のある人である と
それは チェックする 機関があります
厳しく 調べるんです
財産は ありますか と
それくらいの 学問的能力が ありますか？
人格がありますか？ と
厳しく調べて
じゃぁ あんた いいですよ 選挙に出ても と
その紙を もらう
その国だけ
他の国では もう 誰でも いいんです
ですから
それは まぁ いい加減な話しで 言ったんだけど
あんまり関係ない話しで
それも 人間の判断力というのは いかに無責任で いい加減だ ということでしょうにね
どんな世の中を見ても
まぁ それは 置いといて
とにかく この 人間っていうのはね
どんな仕事をしたとしても
やがては もう 何もない
例えば おじさんにしてもね
本当に真剣 真面目に 頑張ったんだけどね
すごい必死になって
もう 頑張った すごい立派な方なんですけど
ぱっと 病気になってしまってね
もうすごい過労でね
で それで もう 倒れちゃって
もう わからない いま どんな調子か と
だから もう 命懸けなんですね
仕事にしても
それに怖くなって いま 何人か 辞めるんだけど
いまさら 気づいてもね
本当は痛かったみたいですね
ボロボロに ボケてしまっても
やっぱり あのケースを見たら すごく ショックを受けちゃってね
まぁ やめた方が いいんだ というふうな
もう 遅いんだけど やっぱり そういうのは 本当に能力ある若者に
元気な時ね 任せた方がいいの
一番きつい仕事でしょうし
たとえ国の総理になったとしても
まぁ そういうことで なんのことなく 虚しく終わっちゃうんですよ
音楽家になっても 売れるか 売れないか
歌を作って 出しても もう 売れるか 分からないしね
結局 そんな人生で いいんでしょうか
タレントさんの なんだか 人生見ちゃうとね
もう 全くおかしいでしょうに
振り回されて
人形みたいに 言われること ばっかしやって
だから すごく 虚しいということを 感じちゃう
弁護士になったって
毎日 毎日 毎日
そういう何かのトラップ
どうすればいいかと 同じものを 調べたりする
虚しく 感じるんですよ
正見が あったら
でも 仏教は それは すごくいいことだ と
やることに執着する必要は ないんだと
すべて 虚しいんだ と 言うんですよ
そこで 虚しく感じたら どうしますかね？
仕事できますかね？
例えば 設計士がいて
すごく苦労して 何か設計する と
それを 自分の会社に 持っていったら
あ これはダメね と一言 言ったら
また ここら辺 全部直して
ここを直して
またやり直すし と言ったら
この人は また 徹夜して
また 2~3週間 苦労しなくちゃいけない
あれは 全部 パーに なっちゃうでしょうに
あるいは 何人かに 頼んで やらせた時は
自分の計画は 全部 そのまま ボツになる場合も あるでしょうに
そうすると 仕事をやる気が なくなっちゃうんです
何でも 虚しいんだから
でも それは 事実だから しょうがないんですよ
たとえ 仕事のやる気が なくなっても
例えば 一生懸命 ものすごい張り切っちゃって 子どもを 育てても
子どもは 大きくなったら 出て行っちゃうんですよ
老夫婦だけ 家に 残っちゃうんです
面倒を 見ようともしない 子どもたちは
そんなことは 最初から 考えちゃうと やる気がなくなっちゃうんです
でも お釈迦様は 最初から それを考えておけ と
結局は 無意味ですよ と
子どもを育てても
最初は 結果は ゼロ と
何も得られません と
そうすると 虚しくなる
やる気も消えるはずですが
お釈迦様は 幸せの道を教えているのです
次のステップは そういうステップなんです
はい こちらです
次に お釈迦様は すごい 安らぎを 教えちゃうんです
こんな くだらんものに とらわれて
どうせ消えるものを つかまえようと思っても
このシャボン玉を つかまえて 家に持っていく というのは そんな無意味でしょうに
すべては シャボン玉や と 思っちゃう方が
お釈迦様は いい言葉を おっしゃってますよ
泡だよ と 全部
この 泡の世界っていうのは
つかまろう 握ろう と 思っても 泡は はじけていっちゃいますから
結局 バカを見るだけなんです
家族も 会社も 仕事も
もう 何でも ただ泡だけ なんです
シャボン玉です
そこを 理解してほしい
そうすると 理解しなかったら シャボン玉を握ろうと思った人が
結局 悲しくなってしまうんです
最初から それを理解する
そうすると まず 言ったような感じで
なんとなく まぁ やったって 意味がないんではないか と
結婚しても 幸せになりっこはないし
子どもがいても 幸せになりっこはないし
仕事をやっても 幸せになりっこはないし
虚しいし 苦しいし
まぁ 嫌だ と
では どうすればいいか という 疑問に 出会うんですよ
それで 6番 正精進
やっぱり やることに 意味があるんですよ
怠けることには 苦しみがあるんですよ
子どもを育てることに 意味があるんです
子どもが大きくなって 親の面倒を見てくれるんだ という
あれは 無意味
あれは 馬鹿を見ること
ただ いま こういうことを やらなくちゃいけない と
そこで 励むこと
仕事をすることに 意味があるんですよ
したんだからといって 会社に褒めてくれるとかね
給料が 上がってくれるとか
それは ないんです
会社は 決して 私を リストラにしてくれないんだとかね
可愛がってくれる それは大嘘で
でも やるものは すごくしっかりと やることには 喜びがあるんです
一番苦しいのは 怠けることですね
やる気がないと
だから 何やっても 結果は 同じでしょうし
だから そんなことを 考える必要は ないんですよ
張り切って 仕事をしたんだからといって
会社は もう お金で計算するんだからね
この人は 簡単に クビにすることができるんだよ と わかったら すぐ捨てますから
そこを 最初から 考えて
やっぱり どうせ クビになるんだからって 仕事をしないと 早くクビになっちゃうんです
5年目にクビになる人は
1年で クビになっちゃいますから
で アメリカだったらあるでしょうし
例えば 子どもの面倒で
どうせ 子どもは他人だから と
法律的には
だから 面倒見なくてもいいんだ と いい加減にしちゃったら
法律で 子どもを 持っていっちゃうんです
親の権利はない と
だから それも また いいわけじゃないでしょう
ですから
子どもは 大きくなって
もう 親不幸しようが
親の面倒を見ようが 見まいが どうでもいいことで
やることに意味がある
ですから 常に それに 精進しなくちゃいけない
という 精進 ということ
やることはしっかり やりましょう と
文句言われないように
だから よく みんな 言うでしょ？
褒めてくれません
認めてくれません
あれは 間違っている考え方なんですね
褒めてくれる必要は ないんです
認めてもらう必要も ないんです
自分の分担は ちゃんと やっておく
はい 勝手にしなさい
それは 向こうの世界だから
自分には 管理できません
それで 働く分は
仕事をする分は
努力する分は
自分には 楽しみは 感じられます
充実感は 感じられます
だから みんな スポーツとか なさってるでしょ
いろいろ健康のためとかね
私は あれよりは
何か 体力を使って 仕事をした方が
もっと充実感を感じるだろうと思いますね
例えば 何時間も 何か 機械の中で 運動したりしたっても
面白くないと 思いますよ
それよりは 自分が住んでいるところは 全部 探検するんだ と
小さな道路から 大きな道路を どこからでも歩いてみる と
そうすると 何か知識でも 来るでしょうね
自分が住んでいる街は 全部 探検は終わった と
で 次の日からは 電車でも ひとつ駅を置いて
そこら辺 また 探検してみるとか
いろいろ 役に立つことが ありますね
で 体力作った方は 店で 買い物したら
それは 宅急便で 送ってもらうんじゃなくて
じゃぁ 持っていくんだ と
その日で 品物は戻るんだからね
これは もう 手が痛くて きついかもしれませんけど
自分の運動にも なります
そうやって 運動の場合でも 意味のある方向へ 持っていけばね
面白いだろうと 思いますけどね
じゃぁ それは正精進 それは そこら辺で終わって
で 7番目 正念
正念というのは
この 瞬間瞬間
物事は 変化しているんだ ということを キャッチすることなんですよ
それで すっごく 面白くなるんです
瞬間瞬間
何でも 変化している
それを キャッチしていくんです
そうすると これ いろんなものに とらわれている心が
何にも とらわれなく なっちゃうんですよ
なんか すごく 安定してくるんです
心が すごく 落ち着いてくるんです
それで 8番目 正定 という 心の混乱は 全部消えちゃう
消えちゃって ものすごく 充実感と 喜びを 感じられるようになる
それは 外の影響では ないんです
いい仕事をしたんだから すごい幸せ
そんな くだらないことじゃ ないんです
そういう 原因と関係なく
心は 統一になっちゃって
心は 何のことなく
すごく 喜びと 充実感を 感じるようになってくるんです
だから すごく この幸せっていうのは
みんな 一人も 感じたことはないんですよ
みんな 幸せっていうのは 一時的な インチキなんです
この心が 安らぎを 感じるんです
世の中で 何が起きても
地震が起きても
火事が起きても
会社が リストラになっても
心ではすごく 充実感と 安らぎ感を 感じるんです
それを 正定 というんです
だから 正見で 暗くなるわけじゃないんです
その しっかりした道なんですね 八正道は
だから 大変な道で
だから 判断する場合は 中道でやりましょう というのは 単純なことではないんです
真ん中の道でも　ないんです
まずは 頭を しっかりしてもらって
それから 言葉を 考え方を コントロールしてもらって
それから 言葉と 行動と 仕事は ちゃんと 整理しておいて
それから 精神的な 心の充実感
安らぎを もらう
それは 自分のもの
子どもを幸せにしてあげた でも
それは 子どものもの
自分のものじゃないんです
それは 自分の幸せ ということになります
そういうことは 判断 決断する 仏教の道なんです
結構 きついかもしれませんけど
そこで 話しは こういう言葉で 終了したいんです
大体 我々は 生きている間では
こういう モットーを 作った方が いいんですね
私は 清らかに生きています
いわゆる 汚れた生き方は しません と
まぁ ちょっと 英語で メモったんだから
なかなか いきなり日本語訳ができなくて
自分の生き方ね
とにかく 清らかな 生き方をします と
間違いを 起こしません
汚れたことはしません と 決める
それから
私は いままでも 悪いこと
いけないこと
後で 後悔することは してもないし
これからも 後で 後悔すること
悪いことはしません と
それで しっかりする
私は もう 後悔することだけは
悪いことだけは しません と
英語で言えば I did not, do not, and will not do evil things. （アイ ディド ノット ドゥー ノット、アンド ウィル ノット ドゥー イーヴル シングス）
というふうな 言葉になりますけどね
間違っていることだけは しません
これから
で しっかり 自信が必要ですよ
いろいろ 誘惑されますからね
だから たとえ 誘惑でも
これは 間違ってるんだからね
やばいんだからね
私はやりません と いままで やったこともないんですよ と
なんで いまさら と
例えば 子どもたちをね
麻薬なんかに 誘惑するでしょう
そうしたら 子どもたちは しっかりしてるんだったら
いままで 使ったことはない そんな変なものはね
やばいものは やりませんよ と
はっきりと 言った方がいい
その時は いくら 凶暴になっても いいんですよ
正しい方法だから
だから 腰抜はよくない
やっぱり 正しい生き方っていうのは かなりきつくて 凶暴なんですよ
私はやりません と
それで 悪いことは 絶対的にやめて
自信をつける 生きる自信を
その時は 他人に批判されないように ということもありますけど
あまり相手を 当てにしない方が いいんですよ
バカどもも いっぱい いるんだからね
時々 悪いことをしない人も 批判する場合があるでしょうに
ですから 相手の批判なんかはね
みんな もう ろくな人間ではないんだから
だからね 政治家には もう 退職もないんだから
そういうぐらいの 判断をする社会だから 我々が生きている世界っていうのは
だから 人の批判はね
あまり 相手にしないで
人は 何と言おうとも
私が 間違っていることはしません と
で その点で 凶暴になってもいい
凶暴っていうのは 自分の生き方を ずっと通してもらう と
別に 凶暴になって 人に暴力をふるうことでは ないんです
それから そういうふうに
最後の言葉 3つしかないんですけど
私は 決して 悪いことをしないで
きちんと 正しく 生きているんだから といって
だからといって 私は すごい大胆な
素晴らしい
とてつもない人間でもありません と
まぁ 単なる生き物で 人間だよ と
ただ みんなと一緒に 生きているだけや と言っておいて
自分のエゴを 消す
例えば ものすごく 頑張って
みんなにいいことをして 頑張っていても
まぁ たまたま やっただけですよ
大したことないんだ と
というふうに思って 自分のエゴを消す
例えば しっかり頑張って 何か 本を作ったりする
いま 本しか 頭に浮かばないんですけど
本を 作ったりする
結構いいもの
自分が すごい真面目に 頑張っちゃったんで いいものが できたりする
それで どうだい？ どうだい？ これはね
これは 私が作ったんだよ とかね
そういう 威張りようになっちゃうと
次に できなくなっちゃうんです
たとえ 人が それを褒めたって
まぁ まぁ そこそこ やっただけで もう 大したことはないんだ と
正直に そう 思うことなんだよ
本当は もっと立派なものが できたはずですよ と言って
自分の心のエゴを 消してもらう
例えば 私の話しを たくさん
私の例を 言うならば
たくさんの人が聞いて
よく仏教を理解して 人生は 幸せになったとする
私は 威張ってはいけません
いえ 大したことはないんだ と
みんなよくできて
よく話しを聞いて 真面目に 頑張ったんだから 起きた結果だよ と
私は 何も やったことじゃないんだ と
私は 知ったことじゃないんだ と
それは 皆様の 努力の結果でしょう と
かえって こちらの方が 感謝したいんだ というふうに 思うこと
私が 感謝したいんだ と
そうやって エゴを消す
その3段階で 生きていれば
物事について 白か 黒か と 決める問題が 解決するだろうと 思います
どうも この辺で 話しを終了させていただきます
どうも ありがとうございます